tensions are flaring again tonight in
the Middle East after Iran seized
control of a British ship apparently an
oil tanker passing into the person's
Gulf through the streets where Moo's
we're joined tonight by congresswoman
Democratic presidential candidate Tulsi
Gabbard of Hawaii she is in Puerto Rico
tonight you can hear the protest and
behind her in the background
in a moment we'll get to why she's there
but first we want to get back to the
breaking news involving Iran congressman
thanks very much for coming on what
should be America's response to the news
today well first of all let's just
recognize that what's happening right
now is very precarious as we move closer
and closer to the brink of war with Iran
look this has got to be above politics
this is not about politics I love our
country I love our people and I'm very
concerned with the direction that we're
taking and the failed strategy that
Trump has I think Trump needs to
recognize at this moment he needs to
open up back channels with Iran get back
into the Iran nuclear deal with the
provision that we need to work towards a
deep militarization and de-escalation of
tensions both with Iran but also Iran's
arch enemies across the Middle East
countries like Saudi Arabia this is so
important we have to put the interests
of our country and our people at the
forefront ahead of everything else to
make sure that we are preventing war and
having a safer country for our people
and for the world
so there is a men by the way and I wish
he weren't in such a small group of
people saying that on both sides right
now thank you for saying it but there's
also news that American troops are going
to Saudi Arabia do you think that that's
a move that will escalate or deescalate
tensions with Iran
you know this this is deeply concerning
in such a personal way these are my
brothers and sisters in uniform who are
leaving their loved ones and their
families behind as they are being sent
out to these countries across the Middle
East really for the sole purpose of this
administration further escalating
tensions with Iran we are in this
situation today because of Trump's
failed policy and strategy really
influenced by people like John Bolton
Mike Pompeo nikki Haley and others we're
first tearing up the Iran nuclear deal
escalating crippling sanctions sending
more and more US troops they are pushing
us closer and closer to the brink of war
which is not good for the American
people not good for our troops will make
us less safe what to speak of the
devastation the damage and the cost both
the human cost as well as the cost on
taxpayers that a war with Iran would
entail this is why it's so important for
the president to do the right thing
right now and to put our country first I
think that's the thing that he wants to
do and I hope that he will do it now
what tell us about the shouting in the
background you are in Puerto Rico I'm
embarrassed to say I don't even have
context for this what are you doing
there and who's yelling
now all week Berto Ricans from across
Puerto Rico have been gathering by the
thousands calling for the resignation of
Governor Rose ayo so the chanting you're
hearing in the background is literally
calling for him to resign
riki resign I'm here in Puerto Rico to
stand in solidarity with my fellow
Americans here who really have been
struggling and suffering living under a
corrupt government for far too long you
know we've been hearing across the
headlines about these leaked chats that
came from the governor with homophobic
slurs and and threats and other things
but really what is driving thousands of
people from all walks of life across
Puerto Rico to gather as they are here
tonight is something much bigger than
what was in those chats it speaks to
this deep-seated corruption that exists
that has put the interests of the rich
and powerful and the elite at the
forefront rather than actually serving
the needs of the Puerto Rican people
for some reason no one in Washington is
willing to admit that so thank you for
saying it out loud clearly everyone in
Puerto Rico knows it's true
tulsi gabbard it's great to see you
tonight and thank you for coming on I
appreciate it thanks Tucker